and finally today
again a little bit more about these
hearings but i'm sorry folks it's the
biggest news in the country right now
fox news
fox news
has of course after they decided to not
air the first hearing and then lost a
bunch of viewers to other networks
decided they've got to start running
them and they have been
and here's what's remarkable you have
hosts on that network
that have finally started to open their
eyes and realize oh my god
this looks bad
neil cavuto has come out and admitted
this looks really bad for donald trump
and martha mccallum this
week said that it was quote stunning
that there was such an amazing lack of
evidence to any of donald trump's claims
of voter fraud let me read the statement
that she said on the air on fox news
this week
it will be extremely useful in coming
campaigns especially the presidential
when you look back at what we have in
terms of the mike pence part of all this
so it is a political discussion it is
very compelling and the lack of evidence
is the huge stunning clear moment here
where these people are saying look i
supported you
please give me something to work with
and it simply
doesn't
materialize
now to be honest martha if you actually
watched any other network other than
your own you wouldn't be stunned by any
of it
like that's the funniest part of all
this she's like oh my god this is
stunning how there's no evidence no
no it's not
it's not stunning to any of us at all
that have been paying attention to this
because there's never been any evidence
even when by the way
republicans have had the opportunity to
provide evidence they have failed to do
it i mean hell mike lindell
ceo of mypillow actually has another
little cyber symposium type thing coming
up in a couple weeks
where he says this time i'm gonna give
you all the evidence all of it every bit
of it
oh really just like you promised us last
august just like you promised us
over the thanksgiving break you're
holding these cyber symposiums you swear
up and down you have all this evidence
and then gosh darn it when it comes down
to it you always just forget to give it
to us whoops right rudy giuliani same
thing claims to have all this evidence
heck the dude even claims to have the
contents of hunter biden's laptop or at
least he claimed at one point he did
nothing
nothing at all
huh
and martha mccallum is stunned by this
that there is no evidence to back any of
this up how are you even stunned okay
even if these people who claim to have
had it don't turn it over
how can you be stunned when we have had
recounts we have had audits we have had
signature verification we have had every
possible thing to look into every
possible election
and nothing materialized
none of this is stunning none of this is
shocking
all you had to do martha which i'm glad
you're doing it now would have been
great if you'd done it a year and a half
ago all you had to do
was open your
eyes
listen that's all the time we have for
today we have a wonderful
members bonus show coming up today
lauren bobert
got a lot more trouble with her coming
up we also have jewel being banned by
the fda but hey if you want more from me
fair and cousins find me on youtube
youtube.com slash the ring of fire
youtube.com fair and balanced i'm on
twitter facebook and instagram at farron
balanced thank you so much for david for
letting me fill in bonus show coming up
shortly this is the david pakman show
thank you for watching